Jimmy Tim Reynolds AP I forgot to ask
you yesterday but there was a little bit
of news in town with Lionel Messi coming
to enter Miami as the
football expert in in the room and
certainly on the team what was your
reaction when you heard that he was
coming and what do you think that means
for soccer in this country
a lot of good obviously he's one of the
greatest players to play that beautiful
game
um and I'm so excited for the City of
Miami to be able to have a player of
that caliber here I'm excited for the
City of Miami in so many different ways
obviously us being in the finals and
having the opportunity to do something
special now that he's here
I think you know all the football side
soccer fans from all over the world are
going to come here and get an
opportunity to watch him compete so I'm
glad he's here hey Kyle Manny Navarro
with the athletic uh I heard a rumor you
were wearing a messy Jersey I think
during the World Cup around yeah yeah
just curious your reaction to the news
that he's going to be playing here in in
MLS man you're getting a lot of money
[Laughter]
uh it's gonna be awesome man I think I
think the MLS is a great league and I
think they understand the um
I thought how to put the product out
there and uh you know bringing one of
the world's greatest soccer football
players out there bringing them here is
going to be awesome
um you know he's gonna he's gonna bring
a different fan base he's gonna get some
more um Revenue going and it's going to
be a great atmosphere when they get that
Stadium built and uh you know the fans
gonna enjoy it and and I think it's uh
great for uh for for soccer in America
um especially down here in Miami